maintenant pour cette mission il ne faut
la crème de la crème
nous savons tous bricman chef et nous
savons qu'ils ramènent alexander vous
devez vous a filtré localiser l'engin et
le désamorcer les passais ma carrière a
essayé d'arrêter tremaine il ne sort
jamais de briques mansion
il ya des barrages partout et on n'a
aucune info sur place aucun contact
contactons la lino du prêt à l'espace
franco entier
sous réserve qu'ils coopèrent il n'est
pas très même déjà cette pilule
hélas pour lacombe qui veut racheter
bien évité quelques angoisses tremaine
alexander a pas beau gosse
hilton d angoisse
sa grâce
je crois qu'à force de rebondir dans
tous les sens ça l'a rendu ma bouche